al yacira presentó ante la Corte Penal
Internacional de la haya una demanda
contra Israel por el asesinato de su
periodista la reportera palestino
estadounidense de sirín abuakle ocurrido
el 11 de mayo pasado el equipo legal de
la cadena catarí dijo que aportó nueva
evidencia para refutar la postura
israelí que no se mueve de la idea de
que a buakle pudo haber sido asesinada
por error en un intercambio de fuego
mientras se cubría una redada del
ejército israelí en yin estas pruebas
incluyen Según a yasira varios relatos
de Testigos presenciales el examen de
imágenes de video y elementos forenses
el medio sostiene como también lo
determinaron otras investigaciones
periodísticas que los soldados israelíes
se dispararon directamente contra ella
pese aportar un chaleco y un casco con
la leyenda de prensa rápidamente el
Primer Ministro saliente israelí ya ir
lapida afirmó que nadie interrogará a
los soldados ni le dará lecciones a
Israel sobre la moral en combate en
especial la cadena de chasira en la
misma línea el titular de recomendó al
Canal katari verificar primero lo que
sucede con los periodistas en Irán
además de esta demanda en la haya Israel
rechaza otra investigación de su Aliado
Estados Unidos que hace unas semanas
anunció una nueva pesquisa del FBI esta
acusación de alya Sira cuenta con el
respaldo del instituto internacional de
prensa y de reporteros Sin fronteras
pero se enfrenta a un potencial
obstáculo Y es que en caso de requerir
arrestos en Israel el estado hebreo no
reconoce la jurisdicción de la Corte
Penal Internacional Palestina en cambio
Si es miembro de la corte y como el
asesinato de agua acre ocurrió en su
territorio eso habilitaría la
investigación de los fiscales
internacionales